la dernière vous qui est une des
premières voix la candidate vous
confirmer tout ça vous aussi on a voulu
vous mettiez en couple voilà qu'on a
l'impression de nous quand on voit ce
genre d'émission on a l'impression ne
disent pas possible ils ont tous des
coups de foudre
ils prouvent tous l'amour et en fait non
non c'est un peu à ça rit ça peut
arriver mais pas arrivé il y en a qui se
posaient sur qui au fur et à mesure
c'est ce que vous pouvez nous raconter
votre casting ben faut cesser
complètement fou que mon cas c'est
complètement fou en face c'est un
premier cas si c'est pas le cas si on
bouge et où j'ai fait les anges c'est
celui d'avant d'accord où j'ai 18 ans
d'accord mais je suis employé est en
fait je suis dans mon casting ou chaud
train d'expliquer en fait aux
producteurs que je suis donc vraiment
c'est le contexte
et quelle est ta vie en ce moment je dis
ben bradshaw en foyer me prête à envoyer
bah voila j'ai pas mes parents inquiets
tu veux faire quoi moi j'aimerais bien
revenir blogueuse a et six mois tu te
rentre souvent des trucs et la regarder
j'ai excusez moi j'ai pas compris la
question c'est à dire tu trouve souvent
des trucs en gros et au détail si je me
rends très des godes dans mon vagin
donc je voyais pas trop où était la
place à la question ce passage était
très perturbé donc j'ai préféré quitter
le tournage - rapper en disant qu'ils
avaient adoré ma réaction évidemment
puisque j'ai insulté producteur mondial
a du caractère quoi ces minutes c'est
quoi ce tribunal pour vous pousser à
bout pour voir si vous avez des
carrières abouties c'est ça l'histoire
en fait c'est ça et on met chaque fois
vous êtes en question quoi d'autre comme
comme question bat même la produit une
productrice donc lors de mon tournage
des anges quand elle a vu que je voulais
pas me mettre en couple elle est venue
me voir en me disant mais dis moi toi en
fait elle fait un casting de [ __ ] et
là tu fais la preuve mais normal gens
comme si c'était une lettre à la poste
tout à fait normal et gt mais genre
juste choquée de ce qu'on veut de lui
majeure
quand je suis allé voir une la
productrice encore pour lui dire le jour
de mon jour off on est en jour off
je ne suis pas censé travailler on est
je suis censé être tranquille à l'heure
actuelle on m'envoie un candidat qui
passe sa journée à me demander combien
je prends pour une fellation que je suis
une escorte à cause d'une paire de
chaussures que j'avais osé porter voilà
apparemment trop jeune pour porter une
paire de chaussures de marque ça voulait
dire que j'avais forcément [ __ ] et du
coucher aller vers la productrice j'ai
fait écouter ça fait depuis rodez
dimanche 16h il ya toute la production
et à tous les journalistes
il ya tout le monde sur mon lieu de
travail on ne train de faire les photos
de la promo ya un candidat qui est en
train de vous dire devant tout le monde
que je suis une escorte qui me demandent
de sucer la [ __ ] m
si c'est ça touche qu'on te dit que tu
aimes tu tu sais que tu en es une ola
l'on répond à ça qu'est-ce qu'on répond
à ça ils ont regardé ce qu'il faut
savoir que la production trembler à
l'idée goût témoigné woo vous êtes très
courageuse
vous avez eu des pressions extrêmement
fortes et jeudi avant que présomption
d'innocence du côté de la production
capture ici ces témoignages sont
confirmées en justice n'est ni plus ni
moins dans l'incitation à la
prostitution
mais si la production il s'avère que la
production organisé légitime et ça bien
sûr on varela pour l'instant les propos
n'engagent que l'engin cogne à
l'espagnol mais c'est vrai que voilà la
production cependant à la vie de la
production à la voile à l'association de
la production dans l'est dans les
prochains jours